not UK right turn it back but it's one
that you just a little bit
[Music]
always
this small same movement just small
[Music]
I'm just moving my body my body
because it is the ski buddy Steve I
for what what's my break your feet
hip-width let's live in deeper
let's oldest right
you
Oh
boom I'm relaxed nope it's no different
it's no different than the moment it's
going to be a rebound energy whose
percussion so we'll take this one out I
don't give you something wrong Hans but
it's percussive
so let's try push yeah
so signs to look for his body this part
that I'm touching will lead in the
forest effect he doesn't move at a zoo
so there's a second word apartheid she
goes in he hasn't moved
go ahead and it doesn't matter where it
is doesn't my ribs are going in right
foot strike
okay okay so don't push right strike
he's okay try to get on the surface do
you see that so same thing we're gonna
try for so you understand surface
surface right and you hear so you see
you this placement how's it feel it does
feel good I'm going to surf this all day
money okay the other thing that's
related to this is those who are going
to adapt you have tension okay and it's
not tension it's not into do you
understand just like she's here well
right right so you're not quite doing it
so the ham is loose
but it's going in either there you were
on when you try to count arrangement
still went in okay so I like it's gonna
hurt or something so you go home
right but then the rest is knocking I
wanted to be relaxed so I one shoe off
to the side there you go
okay go so you felt you felt it hurt
right okay but watch how fast my so
you're not hurt can you come you your
life you're so powerful that I must have
been going really fast
this is one my
okay
that's more application drill boom then
you'll do the displacement
you
yes this is ballistic but there's no
mass displacement you get this has mass
displacement but it's a push wool
percussive boom okay
and yes ring a - text here and then if
you're going to do the other one
watch the live music okay push it to you
you feel like there's a left until your
body pool is floating off my strike now
your body movement so I use her
gravitational pull to create an opposing
force to my stride and I increase right
force at the point of contact with
opposing force you see your body is
pulling on my strike but when I push the
body's getting lighter with my stripes
you see that but when I press your
body's pull anything
tension Oh food even when we go one time
he stopped moving on to doing it so that
is basic pulling against the strike
crazy strike
you
gtatyr you boy this right and home
and then you go right but remember that
is where Dean is other you remember that
and so the second version the first
version is is the first row
and the second one yes
just let it hit you
person but we're going to choose the
bottle right
okay
[Music]
okay he goes but when you're starting
out it's gonna be hard if you're like
this as a beginner like once you go
you'll get to it but so don't do this
keep your form clean wait for that you
build up his resistance he goes down to
the ground and you project it out okay
it's not me
there's this immediately goes down just
like this it's not me moving that hands
there's this there's just wait right
there
don't push yet let that energy go in a
knockdown so you're gonna have contact
you'll feel it and I'll let that go in
now and then when he comes out boom is
when I
you
Oh is the first one we've done this
person right so you drop these are the
head you take it you move it inside they
sing so one look what happened
transportation right it's gonna come
forward so that's what I get now this
boom or
along she comes in so if you get your
Mazda slice you need help some pros
you
Oh
it looks like we're here but I'm not
because her strike was there and her
body's meeting to explain
we're not class you see this okay I'm
not possible
rub my leg
you get it I'm not wrestling here okay
but I'm not walking her